but we are talking about a rock-based
sport a sport I introduced you to many
many years ago wow that's true it was a
cold somewhat rainy day in Ohio was it
it was it was like drizzly out oh okay
all right gotcha it was the day after we
had Skyline Chili that could be any day
it's true but this day we went to the
famous gym in blah blah blah blah blah
blah
[Laughter]
uhhuh yeah oh I remember it so well and
we climbed on the the faithful walls of
The Climbing Gym
of gym Mark what do you remember about
rock climbing in that day that day let
me paint you a mind picture yeah all
right all right my I walk in I've never
been in a gym before in a rock climbing
gym before before I walk in I know that
there's walls and there's rocks but I
didn't understand uh the procedure of
things you know but I I I I'd heard
about it and so I go in there and I'm
I'm you know climbing up uh walls and
I'm like oh this is fun yippi Yahoo uh
whippy meanwhile Tyler is training for
Ninja Warrior and he's like all right
you go on this baby
wall she flushes his muscles a whole
bunch I'm going go on the I'm going to
go on a v
six you know and then he he basically
there's a wall with like a 45° incline
towards you and he's like I can do it I
can do it and I remember you fell and
you you you your hands were like de
gloved at least to my eyes your hands
just like were completely torn up just
like are you having fun he's like yeah I
love it and then he didn't make it into
an N Warrior so Mark it's time to
climb you are no no no you are climbing
no no you are
climbing uhuh safely uhhuh you are doing
climbing with a rope uh-huh what are
some common things that you need to rock
climb a rock okay yes feet that's part
of your body that comes with you
fingernail no not fingernails they
actually get in your way
extensions F extensions yeah no all
right
underwear probably a good plan good plan
right I got that um
when this isn't paragliding this is rock
climbing I got wind you know just in
case I fall back up that doesn't work
love I have love in my
heart um I have uh chalk good good
that's on the list I I have I have a
cage of rabid wolves that are going to
be at the bottom so I never want to go
back all right so motivation got it yeah
exactly motivation and then I have a
fleet of drones to film me as I go up
okay so you're documenting good good
just 13 drones
going like really distracting yeah well
you're going to need your climbing rope
the very right right right I'm sorry I
didn't know it was baby climbing I
thought we were free soloing here taking
this over come here look at me look
at me everybody yeah you know someone in
your life whose life is nothing but
climing there's somewhere around you
that climbs every day religiously it is
their religion and they are dying
they're dying to recruit another one
into their Cult of climb this is what
happened to me with Tyler here those
that climb that's all they do it's a
drug and they keep chasing it and then
they're like yeah just come to the gym
We'll go to the gym oh it's great
bouldering is great ah let's go outside
just go outside and Boulder it's such a
nice day let's go out there let's go out
there let's go on a mountain let's go on
a mountain yeah let's go up a mountain
you like a mountain don't worry it's
like a it's like an incline it's not
straight up oh wait oops we got here
it's straight up I forgot the rope we're
free soloing come on meet you at the
top that's the life cycle
[Music]